et maintenant le monsieur en faire un
jeu un jeu où à mon avis arditi va
briller quand un jeu qui s'appelle
guitry ou ma fille
[Musique]
alors je vous dis les phrases ou dit si
elles sont de sacha guitry ou de laurent
baffie d'accord toi tu as pas le droit
de répondre non merci de nous associer à
sa nature il est à toi tu as aussi pas
tuer associés alors les femmes on les a
dans ses bras puis un jour sur les bras
et bientôt sur le dos sacha guitry
savitri elle et war
une belle-mère c'est la vision futuriste
de sa propre femme ma fille bravo dans
le dictionnaire
la femme est l'avenir de l'homme au
futur des composés non ma fille ma fille
s'est dit non je m'affiche baffie
[Applaudissements]
le mariage c'est l'union fait la farce
en général toute façon quand y'a pas de
mots [ __ ] dedans ça doit être dit très
je pense
c'est ma fille
tu savais que c'était toi oui bon je
l'aï écrite le mariage est comme le
restaurant à peine et ont servi quand on
regarde ce qu'il ya dans l'assiette du
voisin c c guitry ouest
une intellectuelle est une femme de
ménage baffie bien
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est tellement bien écrit que ça
aurait pu être de dietrich
ni et dieu sait se priver de l'unique
intérêt que présente la mort sacha
guitry mois
attention mon passé très présent rend
mon futur imparfait
aller bafia les bassidji mais
il n'y a pas le gros beats un voisin qui
les cas si la vie est une période
aléatoire entre le néant et le néant ça
pourrait être schopenhauer ou spinoza ou
spinoza et ya spin dans spinoza
ma fille ma fille bravo
ça va loin et la dernière on rate sa vie
et pour essayer de la rattraper on écrit
pour transformer sa vue et puis sont
écrits plus on rate sa vie or rien ne
peut remplacer la vie à moi je souhaite
pour le rang que ce soit ma fille parce
que j'ai envie de connaître de son
vivant l'auteur de cette phrase se dit
d'avis très tepa guitry c'est christine
angot ton à 1000 euros
mais je me disais c'est mal écrit
les corrections de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux